I'm June Sarpong and I'm
the author of Diversify.
I was disabled for
four years of my life.
When I was a teenager,
I was hit by a car,
didn't walk for two
years, and then I
had to wear a neck
brace for another two.
The thing that was just
so strange about it
for me was the way
people reacted towards me
after the accident.
The way people
treated me, it was...
I almost saw a kind
of dumbing down.
It was the most bizarre thing.
And I think that
experience is what
has made me so passionate
about this issue
because I wasn't any
different as a person,
but the world certainly
reacted to me in that way.
This is a quote
from George Bush,
not somebody I quote often.
And this quote was in relation
to African-American kids
in the inner cities
but what he spoke about
was the soft bigotry
of low expectations.
And that really applies
for our disabled community.
We've looked at gender.
We've looked at BAME.
We're now looking at disability.
Could you imagine having
500 Sheryl Sandbergs,
leaning in for disability
and with disability?
We would get this done.
If we want disability to be
meaningfully at the business
table we need the leaders.
It's got to be the leaders.
The uncomfortable truth
is, they don't exist.
I believe, and many do, that
the diversity and inclusion
agenda is very
difficult for business,
where we're pitting
humanity against each other.
This year, we'll do gender.
We'll do race.
We'll ..do Next
year, we'll do LGBTQ.
What are we talking about?
A la carte and
pick-and-mix inclusion?
Are you kidding me?
Since when did we think it
was OK to have a hierarchy
of exclusion or inclusion?
My name's Erin Boyce.
I work at Alliance Learning and
I'm a business administrator,
currently an apprentice.
I'm registered blind.
I have a condition called
retinitis pigmentosa.
Actually, I moved out of my
parents' house about a week
after I left college.
I really felt determined
to get out and start living
this new chapter of my life.
So that was in the July
that I left and I moved out.
I thought my
prospects were pretty
positive about getting a job.
And then I was
applying to things
and I wasn't getting
anything at all.
And at this point I was still
putting my visual impairment
on my CV.
I felt like it was all
framed in a positive way
and it shouldn't
have put them off.
But I didn't get any
kind of response at all.
Then in October I decided
to take that off my CV
and I got two
interviews that month.
And I didn't put it on again.
I went to 18 interviews.
And for most people
that's the give-up point.
And I didn't because I
really still wanted to work,
so I kept going for it.
But I know a lot of
people who have given up,
and those are people that
are perfectly able to work.
And if you reached
out to them and you
said, hey, we know this
employer is accepting,
we know that they are
willing to make adaptations,
maybe you should
apply to them, you're
going to get high-quality
applicants because, actually, I
know in the case of visually
impaired people in general,
there is actually a
higher rate of them
going to university
than the general public
because they know that their
chances of getting a job
are much worse.
So they go into higher
education more often.
I really do think it is
a massive opportunity
for employers.
And it's something,
being on the inside now,
having this opportunity to
hopefully make a difference
if I can, having had
my personal experience.
I'm trying now to actually get
us to tap into that because I
think there are just...
there's this massive amount
of high-quality
applicants out there.
And they're more resilient.
They're more loyal.
When you've slogged through
all these interviews
and you've had all
these things said to you
and you feel like utter garbage,
and then somebody treats you
like you're not
a burden for once
and they're willing to make
all these adaptations for you,
you know what you've
got at that point.
So Alan, here we
have the statistics
relating to disability
and employment in Britain?
That's right.
Probably bleaker than any of
the other data we've looked at.
Well, it depends
how you look at it.
I mean, one thing
I could say is we
could start with a
good-news story, June,
which is that if you look
at from when the figures
that we've got that we can
go back as far as 2013,
there's a consistent
trend in the employment
rate of disabled people.
Consistent increase, yeah.
Both for men and for women.
And in fact, the employment
rate of women with disability,
you can see it's actually
accelerated a little bit faster
than the employment rate
for men with disability
and crucially has crossed
this 50 per cent line
for the first time.
So the employment rate
overall for both men and women
is now over 50 per cent.
But just over 50 per cent.
Just over 50 per cent, and so...
And we would not be celebrating
that for any other group.
Exactly.
So in fact, that's exactly
where this term, the disability
employment gap, pops up
because that line now
looks slightly less impressive.
That's the same data we've just
been looking at, starting at 0
and finishing at 100.
So this is the entire
scale of the chart,
and you can see this is a
very modest improvement.
But I mean, the real putting
those numbers into context
really only happens when you put
the employment rate for people
without disability on top.
OK?
And so you can see that
there really is this...
this thing.
And this is what we're calling
the disability employment gap.
And if you look at
how those figures have
changed since 2013, there's been
a modest narrowing of the gap.
It was 33.1 percentage
points back in 2013.
It's now down to 28.9 per cent.
My name is
Gemma-Louise Stevenson,
and I am a freelance
reporter for Sky Sports.
Alongside my reporting,
I'm also an athlete.
I don't like to stop.
I'm quite busy.
I just want to live
life to the full,
and I want to make
the most of life.
Oh, my god.
Yeah.
So Gemma, here we are at
Sky, your place of work...
my place of work
sometimes too, actually.
I'm going to ask you what sounds
like a very dumb question.
But for employers, how do they
advertise to disabled people?
So what is that?
What is the thing that they
need to do to make it very clear
that this is who
they're targeting?
I mean, I think for me, it's all
very well having these training
schemes.
Like, I went through a
training scheme myself.
However, it was a very
negative experience
because the whole atmosphere
wasn't inclusive originally
to start with.
OK
I they're a good idea, but
I'm also very cynical of them
because you can have all these
great, inclusive training
schemes to get people
into the workplace,
to show them what it's
like, to give them
experience so that they
can then go in a job.
But if the workplace
to start with
is not an inclusive
workplace, you're
not going to retain those staff.
One thing I find about the Sky
is, they're very inclusive.
They treat me as an individual.
I'm seen as a reporter
first before a wheelchair
user who happens to
be a reporter, which
is so important.
Whether you're a
reporter like myself
or whether you're working
in HR or in administration,
you are working in HR, you
are working in administration,
you're working in media,
before your disability.
I use the social
model of disability,
which is the favoured version
amongst the disabled community.
So it's not saying that my
illness makes me disabled.
It's the environment
around me not being
accessible makes me disabled.
What's your message to
employers, and particularly HR
directors, in terms of what they
can do when they are creating
an application and
also making sure
that that application reaches
people with disabilities,
and then secondly, once they do
hire people with disabilities,
make sure that they're able to
thrive within their companies?
I think my biggest point
would be, treat everybody
as an individual.
Ah!
One thing...
Oh, no, no, no, no.
This is powerful.
Yeah.
It's not about treating
everybody equally as such.
It's treating everybody
as an individual,
understanding that we all
have individual needs.
Yeah, because we all have
different needs to be equal.
To achieve equality is really
based on treating everybody
as an individual.
Yeah.
It's very much talk to
the person because we
as disabled people are
very good at communicating.
Because you have to be.
We have to.
Yeah.
And do you know what?
We know it's not
going to be perfect.
We know it's never...
we're not striving
for perfection.
We're just striving for a way
to work that enables us to work.
Striving for inclusion.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And things will go wrong.
Even in the most
inclusive environments,
things will go wrong.
But do you know what makes the
difference between an employer
I want to stay with
and an employer
I want to leave behind?
The difference is is
that they listen to me.
Hi, my name is Caroline
Casey, and I'm the founder
of The Valuable 500.
In the BAME episode, we
talked about the dangers
of blanket terms.
Yeah.
When you lump all people
of colour together when
their lived experiences
are so different.
The same applies to
disability, whether...
Absolutely.
...whether it's physical,
sensory, or cognitive.
It's a very different
lived experience.
And then acquired or congenital.
There you go.
You've just talked about
BAME or the soft bigotry.
Look what we're finding out.
This conversation
about disability
is no different, right?
This is not rocket science.
But what I find very interesting
to your question about why
is the issue of disability
so on the edges of business
is because of the fear
of the complexity,
the fear of getting it wrong.
And actually, I'll
be really honest.
They would rather try
and deal with things
that may be simpler and more
straightforward and easy
because can you imagine
what a business has
to deal with in trying
to get it all right?
And I've noticed with
disability, they say,
but what do we do, Caroline?
What do we do?
And I'm like, but
what did you do
when you started to
have the conversation
about the environment?
What did you do when
you started to have
the conversation about gender?
Surely, you looked at what's
happening in your business.
And what's happening
elsewhere that's working.
What did your competitors do?
What did people outside do?
Did you go to experts?
Did you talk to the
cohort of people?
Because the most important
thing about disability
is just to ask.
Yeah, just to ask.
I don't know what your
lived experience is.
You don't know what mine is.
But we can have
the conversation.
When you look at the employment
rates for different types
of disability, you realise that
looking at averages is very
dangerous because, actually, for
some disabilities like hearing,
the employment rate's
well over 60 per cent.
Yes.
But actually, down
here we've got things
like epilepsy, mental
illness, speech impediments.
Learning difficulties.
Yeah, exactly.
And those rates are
very, very different.
So in fact, when you
look at the average
that we were just looking
at, which is just over half,
51 per cent, you can see there's
the disability employment
gap that we were looking at.
But look at these people
here with these kinds
of disabilities.
The gap is much wider.
Nowhere near.
They're nowhere near even
the average of people
with disabilities in general.
Exactly.
So with something
like epilepsy only,
the employment rate is
around about 33 per cent.
But is...
I would've thought there are
certain forms of disability
because the thing
with this is obviously
people are self-identifying.
There are a lot of people who
cover their disabilities, one
of the things that Caroline
Casey was talking about.
This is something
she did herself.
I would have thought
there were a lot
of these forms of disabilities
that people probably
don't actually report.
Yeah.
I mean, that's one
of the weaknesses
of a self-reported
survey, which is
that you're entirely reliant
on someone submitting
that information.
And I mean, I think even
with physical disabilities,
looking at this data,
the thing that's
really interesting is not
one of these categories
actually reaches the
employment rate of people
without disabilities anyway.
Of course, the other thing that
we can talk about with this,
is that what we're seeing
here is our best data
that we have on
this at the moment,
but it's nowhere near like as
comprehensive as the data we
would get for something
like the gender pay gap
where we're asking
companies to report.
This is... this is a
quarterly survey...
Do you think that's the sort
of thing that needs to happen?
Do you think that we
need reporting on this?
Obviously, there's
discussions around reporting
on BAME and pay gaps.
I think that certainly
the same arguments
that you could make historically
until we got the gender
reporting and now with
the pressure for BAME,
I think you can make exactly the
same arguments for disability,
partly because what we've
been looking at up to now
is just the employment rates
and this general pattern.
The physical disabilities have
slightly higher employment
rates generally than mental.
But in fact, the Equalities
and Human Rights Commission
have carried out some analysis
of the disability pay gap.
And that takes us much
more into this territory
where we're
thinking, well, where
do we start talking about
a requirement for companies
to report?
Can we talk about the role
legislation has to play?
So...
Very important.
I'm very interested in
some of the stuff that's
going on in China in terms
of actually mandating
large businesses to make
sure that a percentage
of the workforce is from
the disabled community.
What are your thoughts on
that kind of legislation?
OK.
So the quota question comes up.
What I'm worried about
on the quota systems,
in many of the OECD countries
who have these quotas about
employment figures, which
are often around 10 per cent
representation in the
employment body...
And fines if you
don't meet them.
50 per cent of
them pay the fines.
I know.
They write them...
Into their budgets.
...into their budgets.
So I'm just like, ugh.
So then there's no point
to having legislation
if we are not going to
stand over our legislation.
Yeah.
I'm Yana Kakar, the global
managing partner of Dalberg.
It was wonderful to have your
team observe the roundtable
and sort of take
away the nuggets
and then compile a to-do, an
action point, for CEOs and HRs.
Often there is a
real focus on, am I
recruiting a sufficiently
diverse group,
or am I incentivising
them sufficiently?
But understanding how diversity
drives better team performance
and then how to incentivise
diversity across the lifecycle
once you have a diverse
set of employees,
that's where the trick is.
If you think about what's the
value, what's the performance
value that we're talking about
from diversity and inclusion,
it's the diversity
of the thought
and the decision making and
the risk aversion and stopping
groupthink.
And just on that,
I mean, we still
have on those
dimensions of diversity
pretty poor measurement
and metrics,
beyond the identifiable
characteristics.
And it's good that we're doing
a better job of recording those.
When it comes to
personality differences,
cognitive differences,
we're still at the foothills
there of thinking about how
to get a fix on that when
building genuinely diverse
teams across all its dimensions.
The composition of the balance
of characters in the team
is so critical.
Exactly.
And the notion, as
Helena was saying,
of genuinely
team-based recruitment,
performance evaluation,
and promotion,
that's... we're still a
world away from having.
Ignition is a brewery
in southeast London.
We have a taproom
as well, and we
sell draft ale and bottled ale.
Our secret is that our
staff team have learning
disabilities, but the beer they
make is so good that we're able
to sell it and pay them the
London living wage of £10.55
an hour.
Wow.
I mean, we've been looking
at the data in relation
to people with disabilities
in the workplace
and particularly
learning disabilities.
That group in particular
earn the least
and are the least
likely to be employed.
Is that why you decided to focus
on that side of disability?
Sort of.
So yeah, you're
absolutely right.
It was 94 per cent
of people had no job.
They've actually
stopped measuring it,
so I think the government
now have just given up.
Because it's so bad.
What's the point?
You're trying to sell an idea.
And I think what we've
learned about this
is, it's about people.
People employ people.
And also to create
the kind of culture
where your employees can
thrive because if you're
taking somebody with
learning disabilities
into an environment that
isn't prepared for them,
sometimes you can be doing
that employee a disservice.
So what's wonderful
about here is,
you've created the
kind of environment
that's inclusive enough for
all your employees to thrive.
Oh, thank you.
And I think...
It matters.
I think what's good
about this is, actually,
a lot of the changes that we've
made in comparison to places
where I've worked
before, actually we've
got a much healthier culture.
And I've now gone
and employed those
in places where I will work.
And it's a lot of the things
we've had to do about being
patient or getting a good
routine or having a healthy...
the way in which you talk to
each other being really healthy
are actually just
things anyone should do.
And I think we are an
extreme version of what
I'd like the world to be
because our team is obviously
very special.
But I think the
impact that someone
could have with a learning
disability for the better
in your business is really good
because it's great for morale.
It's also great for
sort of, I think,
getting people just to
behave better and think,
actually, I'm at work, and I
need to show a good example,
and I need to be
a better person.
You're an economist by trade.
Yes.
We won't hold that against you.
But do you think that also
influenced your decision
to actually do something
about this problem,
knowing how many
people were out of work
and how much we're losing
out on as an economy
as a result of that?
Yeah.
So it was a kind of... it's
a financial gamble in a way,
I thought.
The best way to show that our
guys can generate you profit
an income is set up a company.
Is to show it.
Yeah.
And so we've taken
people with no...
I have no brewing experience.
They have no brewing experience.
I'm not mad about beer.
I quite like our beer.
And actually, we've created a
business that is surplus making
and is a good employer
based on their talents.
For anybody wanting to replicate
your model, for corporations
who want to look at doing
something like this on a larger
scale, what are the pitfalls?
What are the difficulties?
Because let's be
frank about that too.
So I think it's a
big cultural change.
And we all know cultural
change is the hardest.
Yeah, it's really
difficult. And there
needs to be buy-in at the
top, is the first thing.
So the top honcho,
they need to say
I'm really committed
to this, and we're
going to make it happen.
And without that,
it won't happen.
It's very simple.
And then I think
there's been a lot
of the kind of
systematisation of employment
for people with disabilities.
So there's a checklist, and
they make them interview-ready.
Then there's a CV-ready thing.
And we just largely
discarded that too.
You did?
Yes, we did.
We did.
So you got rid of
that whole process.
So what we've done is,
we've started very much
with the people and said,
do you want to work with us?
Are you really keen?
Yeah.
And then they'll say, yes.
OK.
Well, come and just do a shift
because, actually, that's
the best way for us to learn,
because even if they can't
do any of it, that's fine.
But you can tell if
the aptitude is there.
And if they sort of go, OK...
because pulling a pint is
actually really... well,
I find it really hard.
And so...
It is.
I've never done it.
It's really difficult
because it come...
the head's too big.
It's too small.
It's too flat.
It's too cold.
But you can tell if
someone's going to keep
on going till they get it.
And then once they
get it, it's...
They've got it.
If you want to truly, I suppose,
maximise the performance
potential of your diverse
teams, you bring them on board,
and then you identify where
are there sort of hidden
constraints to top performance?
Where are there ways in which
diversity, which we know
has been statistically
proven to be a key driver
of financial performance?
I mean, it was shocking to
me to see that it was so...
so well quantified
that literally it's
a percentage of increased
financial performance
if you have a diverse team.
And you can just see the
needle go up and down.
But yet there's
still resistance.
There is.
It makes no sense.
I know.
Well, it's...
you sort of...
we spend enough time, I
think, on the diagnosis
or the demonstration
of the business case.
OK.
But then committing and
executing the action...
that's what the next step is.
Yeah.
OK.
So we have workforce.
Let's talk about customers
and consumers in terms of what
a CEO or a leader within an
organisation can do to add
value in relation to
diversity for the customers.
The interesting thing about
customers, or consumers,
is, it is only a medium-known
fact the degree to which
the diverse consumer is growing
in strength, buying power
strength, decision-making
power strength.
I found it fascinating.
One of your attendees at the
CEO roundtable, Karen Blackett,
CEO - powerful CEO in her own
right - and she said, look,
over the last decade, we have
seen minority buying power go
from £30bn-odd to £300bn.
So let's just...
let's pause and
think about that.
Yeah.
So shifting gears to say, well,
who is this diverse customer
that I have out there,
and understanding...
That I'm not servicing properly.
Exactly, and understanding,
how do I actually
tailor myself, my product, my
solution, my approach, in order
to capture them?
The most provocative way to get
anybody in business interested
is to look at their bottom line.
Yeah.
So let's just talk about the UK.
OK.
You're worth £249bn.
billion.
That is what this disability
community is worth.
There's massive competition
going on on those high streets.
Why are you not listening?
I think it's really
interesting when
we see that supermarkets
supplying for the 400,000
vegans because they
see it as value, right?
But let's be honest, because
they see it as value.
Well, what about
Twenty per cent
of the population?
What about 20 per cent
of the population here?
So I think Barclays have
always made the intention very
clear they want to be the most
accessible and inclusive FTSE
company.
And they do that through
their consumer offering.
But the best example of all
time for any of this is Apple.
Really?
Why?
How so?
Because Steve Jobs, we know,
was probably very difficult,
but he was a visionary.
And he wanted to create
the most beautiful products
that everybody else in
the world could use.
That's called universal design.
Apple was the very
first brand in the world
to reach $1tn Why do
you think that is?
It's because there are more of
us who can use their products.
Actually, Apple is a brand that
most of the disabled community
will choose.
So was that a consideration
when they were designing...
Yeah.
He just wanted to have...
Wow, their hardware.
... beautiful products...
I had no idea.
...for everyone.
Now, they don't shout
about being an inclusive
or an accessible company.
It's universal design.
Sometimes we forget
that if we get
design right for the full
spectrum of disability,
we'll probably get it
right for all of us.
I kind of think the business
case to incentivise business,
let me just tell you,
it's an $8tn market.
It's a brand opportunity.
It's an uncluttered space.
It's the acquisition
and retention of talent.
It's about innovation.
It's productivity.
The next generation really
care about spending money
and working with companies that
allow you to be who you are.
Why have we not seen
accelerated change?
I'll go back to
where we began...
because the most powerful
force on this planet
is making a decision to leave
the disability community
as an invisible market.
And unless it gets
into this game,
meaningfully invests
in it, we will
continue to see, no
matter what, no matter
what legislation you do in the
world, because let's be honest.
Money runs the world -
power, money, business.
It affects politics.
And I don't think any
legislation will be able
to solve this if businesses
don't take responsibility,
but...
and take up the opportunity.
I believe diversity has
a triple-line benefit
to business for innovation,
productivity, and bottom line.
It's a triple-line
bonus, the individual,
to society and peace at large,
and to the business bottom
line.
I mean, what is not to like?